so to judge the likelihood of a 2020
Hillary campaign we're joined tonight by
a man who was served for decades as one
of her closest aides Philippe rains
sleeps great to see the night you too
Tucker
so I'm assuming what I just said and
what we're hearing is true that if she
thought she was the best position to
beat Donald Trump she'd get in the race
she's not I would take issue with the
Macedonia part but other than that I you
know she ran for president because she
thought she would be the best president
if she still thought that now if she
thought she had the best odds of beating
Donald Trump I think she would think
about it long at heart I know she's not
she doesn't foreclose the possibility
she has nothing so really the question
and that doesn't surprise anybody who's
followed the house right so I guess the
question is has the Democratic Party
changed so much in the last three years
that it would be possible for Hillary
Clinton to get the nomination so in
other words a lot of Democrats say well
Hillary Clinton is the real president it
was stolen from or whatever but at the
same time you think maybe they've
changed and they don't want her anymore
maybe she's too right-wing
well look this is a huge if but if she
had a jump in for whatever reason and
the party has moved someplace that she
hasn't then she won't get the votes
that's the point of the primary there
are I guess still 19 people there are a
few that are in double digits if she
would have run and people think that
she's - left - right - Center whatever
you want to call it that's the beauty of
it they get to vote against whoever they
want I don't know she's not running
because she has any anxiety about the
diabetic field she really likes a lot of
the people running she knows the well
she thought about some of them for her
Vice Presidency but there might be a
reason that she'd be the best person not
only to beat Donald Trump but to govern
after Donald Trump which is a part we
don't talk about much and look you could
make fun of her all you want but 65
million people voted for her and that's
decade or more Danny wasn't your mom I'm
not making fun of her actually I watched
Foxman actually use the mill president
hold on I'm the guy we don't talk about
her very off oh come on
but I walk out right now because I think
it's so interesting Hillary Clinton who
I've always thought was at the leftward
edge of the Democratic Party and has
been for 50 years since her 1969 speech
at Wellesley College has been on the
leftward edge of the Democratic Party
she denounced Bernie Sanders Medicare
for all
proposal as a terrible conversation to
have she's like completely against it
the lady knows her health care I mean
she was ahead of her time in 1990 for
the nomination if you stood up and said
it's terrible well you know what that's
a debate that the party's having right
now that you know the candidates that
are for Medicare for all or defending
how it would be structured how we pay
for and the ones who were against our
pressing those questions I mean if it's
a health care debate I think I would
take that and I'd put my but it's not
just health care actually so why would I
put up on the screen a quote you tell me
who said this this is from 2015 Kate
Steinle of course murdered right and the
mark Adaro down in San Francisco hears
Hillary Clinton's response what should
be done is any city should listen to the
Department of Homeland Security which is
I understand it urged them to deport
this man again after he got out of
prison another time here's a case where
we've deported we've deported we've
deported he ends up back in our country
and I think the city made a mistake the
city made a mistake not to deport
someone that the federal government felt
strongly should be deported I have
absolutely no support for a city that
ignores the strong evidence that should
be acted on whoa but here's the that's
not racism I don't know what is that's
not racism usually port the guy know oh
my god you thinking deporting people is
racist I mean no I know for a fact that
I personally have been denounced as a
racist for using the word deport because
he's a Latin American that's that's
right I don't know you haven't been
following your party reason that's
racist what she just said I looked you
know that I played Donald Trump in 2016
when she was pressing for a debate I
threw those quotes at her like anything
else
I threw Kate Steinle at her but look you
know there's a difference who now and
then the man now has a record he's been
there for three years and while make
America great again was really the
tagline that got the most attention he
said something else in 2016 which was
what do you have to lose and I think if
we now ask ourselves that question 40
percent of us are going to say we don't
we haven't lost anything we've gained 60
percent of us seem to think that we have
lost and one of those things is
immigration is people's freedom and one
of those things is health care so when
she says that it's not racist when Trump
says it is okay so but that was pretty
clear anyway guns against Donald Trump I
don't think it's if it's a referendum on
racism I think we're gonna happen
coming year you have someone who's
calling for explicit racial quarters or
people are kept out of jobs in schools
because their skin color that's right
bottom line here is immigration and you
have I know you believe that the
president's plan on immigration has not
worked
that's not gotten anywhere it is not
what you believe this would be so let me
let me ask you this just last week yeah
she and her daughter Chelsea Hawking yet
another book not rich enough apparently
with The Sunday Times a book about women
through the ages right okay this is an
interview they did with a British
publication the Sunday Times and they
were asked the journalist Decca akin had
asked the Clintons if someone what with
a beard and a penis can ever become a
woman to what Chelsea replied emphatic
ly yes yes of course of course
twitch Hillary looked uneasy and then
said this or I'm just learning about
this she responded erasing trans people
in the program in the process it's a
very big generational discussion because
this is not something I grew up with her
ever saw it's gonna take a lot more time
and effort to understand what it means
to be defining yourself differently
that's transphobia if there ever was
transphobia the LGBT community knows
where she stands she did really
Secretary of State was she made sure to
give passports to people in gay
relationships she made sure that if they
had a health problem that we'd fly the
relationships are different from this
okay everyone had to bundle this all
together
this is a very specific question about
trans orthodoxy and Hillary Clinton's
like it makes me uncomfortable that's
creepy you're not allowed to say that
Philippe look with them this is the
thing if she were to run which is
unlikely I mean I if you gave me a
choice between betting on her running or
betting on Powerball I probably bet on
Powerball but if she were to run people
get to decide I know you do the cottage
industry is in some extent she might as
well run she's become like the most
reasonable person the Democratic Party
that's the air she might be the best
person to beat president pencil I'm
sorry I meant President Trump
sleep brains great to see you great to
see thank you